hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar single-cell phosphoprotein
analysis with site off from training to
amino oncology clinical research i'm
susie valdez of laborat and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and brought to you by fluid
I'm to learn more about fluid I'm visit
them at ww1 I'm calm so let's get
started before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at anytime you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of your presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I now present today's
speakers dr. Jonathan Irish the
assistant professor in the department of
cell and developmental biology and
scientific director of the cancer and
amine ology core at the Mass cytometry
Center of Excellence and our second
presenter Carolyn Rowe the managing
director of the cancer and immunology
core at the Master tamo tree center of
excellence for complete biography on our
speakers please visit them at the
biography tab at the top of your screen
our speakers will now begin their
presentations welcome both of you
great thank you for the opportunity to
talk today I'm Johnathan Irish and I'll
give this first part of the talk and
I'll be followed by Caroline Rowe from
my group and our focus today is on
measuring posture protein signaling with
mass cytometry and we're going to try to
cover the gamut from training and your
first fossil flow experiment all the way
to applying phosphate flow cytometry to
primary human tissue samples in immuno
oncology clinical research and I'll go
fairly quickly through some of the
slides today and so I wanted to point
out that the work that I'll talk about
in my section is all up on bio archive
and I have the URL listed here and it's
okay to bring shot this and to review
the slides that I'll show today my
disclosures are listed in the lower
right so the work that we're doing is
part of a large multi investigator
clinical studies that includes
pathologists and neurosurgeons who
collect the tissue and then our group
which focuses on the green and orange
parts of the pie here where we work at
the bench applying that cytometry to
characterize all of the cells from human
tissue samples and then also develop
computational algorithm that can analyze
the data and our goal with the
computational tools that we'll show
today is to create an entirely
unsupervised analysis workflow and
unsupervised means that the human
doesn't need to provide any information
either about the clinical outcome of the
patient or about what types of cells the
algorithm should find it just works on
its own to find the cells and ultimately
these studies are really powerful when
you can go entirely around the wheel and
design new clinical studies new clinical
research based on the findings and so
we'll try to make it all the way around
the wheel from collecting samples
applying map cytometry
finding new cell subsets and stratifying
outcome doesn't thinking about where it
could go in the future
and so upfront I should acknowledge that
this is an amazing collaboration with
dr. Rebecca Aires lab also here at
Vanderbilt and it was powered on the
clinical side by Brett Mobley a
neuropathologist and dr. Eck Sheik kamar
mystery a neurosurgeon in the Erie lab
and then as well null allele at Ian and
Justine Tanev are the graduate students
who are Co first authors on the study
and did a lot of the bench work and
design the data analysis strategy more
recently Sarah Berlin is a research
assistant in my lab who scripted is a
machine learning workflow so that it now
runs in 15 minutes with no human input
needed and Todd Bart Kubiak have joined
the project and is exploring the immune
infiltrate and there's a lot of work
that built up to the current study and I
don't have time to go into all of the
background today and so there are four
key studies listed on this slide that
helped us prepare for the work that I'll
present today so the first one is the
basis for the data analysis strategy
that I'll talk about and so if you're
interested in the machine learning
workflow why we're using teeth knee and
float zone for clustering as well as
marker enrichment modeling check out
this first paper by Jocelyn gentlemen
that was published in hematologic ah
where she applied a similar workflow to
look at patient medical phenotypes the
second reference listed here is a review
article where dr. mystery and I sort of
go through the logic for ymf cytometry
is a really powerful tool where solid
tumor analysis because it's relatively
new to apply single cell tool to solid
tumors and mass spectometry is very
complementary with other techniques like
single cell or in a seat or multiplex
quantitative imaging and so we walk
through some of the advantages of mass
spectometry in that article the third
one is
studies i le green plate senior graduate
student who finished in my lab this is
the culmination of her thesis research
where she develops a longitudinal immune
monitoring strategy and computational
tools to go with that and so if you're
interested in especially the Mariners
from modeling labels and the comparison
of them and want to think about what if
you like to apply them over time this is
a study AZ
does that and then lastly if you're
interested in the development of mass
spectometry for solid tumors and how we
built our panel this last reference ID
on-dock see another grad student in the
lab built a panel for melanoma research
and applied it to look at biopsies of
melanoma tumors over time on targeted
therapy and so that work sort of goes in
the logic of building the panel and so
what I will talk about today is applying
mass spectometry to glioblastoma tumors
to reveal risk stratifying cells and the
machine learning tool rapid is that we
developed to do that
and then how we validate these findings
both in a statistical sense and in the
biological sense and how we're hoping to
go beyond the clinical research in this
work
so the tumors that all show today are
all idh wild-type glioblastoma
so glioblastoma is the primary brain
tumor in adults these are highly
aggressive tumors and there is no
targeted therapy that prolongs the
survival of these patients the last
major change was the addition of the
alkaloid and chemotherapy
Amma's Olamide to surgery and radiation
and the median survival with that is
currently 14 and a half months so we
really need something better and I think
that understanding the different types
of cells and the signaling biology these
cells will be really critical to moving
beyond the current therapies so this is
really part of a trajectory that I've
been working on since graduate school in
Gary Nolan's lab and my postdoc with Ron
levy where we looked at self signaling
in acute myeloid leukemia in grad school
and then follicular lymphoma in the
postdoc and in both cases we found
subsets of cells defined by differential
signaling and signaling responses that
stratified the outcome of those patients
and so the main question here today is
will fossil flow now measured by Mouse
psychometry also be able to stratify the
outcome of patients with a solid tumor
in this case glaucoma
so how do we start to design a panel and
we don't need to sort of memorize and go
through the biology of every single
protein along the left here but these
are all proteins that are important in
neural cell development and in the brain
and that can mark different brains all
subsets and the cell types that they
might mark in healthy development are
listed along the top going from left to
right it's the most immature cells in
this case the d1 cells that are a stem
or progenitor cell in the brain and
going to the right two more
differentiate itself including mature
astrocytes for example or the brain
resident microglial macrophages and you
can see that where our goal here is to
get multiple markers to find all of the
cell types one might normally find in
the brain because the cancer cells the
glue blastoma cell
aberrantly co-expressed many different
features and so I'll just highlight four
features that are going to be really
important throughout the talk
these are EGFR doc - x100 B and cd44 and
we didn't know it ahead of time we knew
that these might be important they're
associated with stem cell biology but we
found that EGFR and cd44 will be
associated with better outcome or
positive prognostic self docks - and
f100 B will be associated with negative
prognostic bells and so these were four
of the features on our map cytometry
panel that's listed here so each row is
a different feature that we are
measuring you can see the antibody clone
that it was included in the panel
whether it was included in teeth knee
analysis and the step at which we
stained it and one of the key points
here is that some of the features were
stained while the cells were alive with
an intact cell membrane others were
stained actors - ponen permission or
methanol permeabilization which
generally works really well for fall so
protein so some other key features in
the panel includes CD 31 and CDs 45 -
Merck endothelial cells and lymphocytes
and then many of the markers in the
panel many of the features we measured
were to go after stem cell biology
including neural stem cells we really
thought this was going to help us
stratify patient outcome and as we'll
see these words the driving features of
this of the clinical outcome stratifying
population but they were interesting and
important features within the tumor
we also measured lots of functional
outcomes including LDAP proliferation
apoptosis and DNA damage responses with
things like membrane permeabilization
increased cap space 3 gamma h2ax and
other features and then my favorite part
is we measured lots of spots for protein
signaling effectors to cast a wide net
and understand whether the signaling
network had been activated or with an
arresting state at different key nodes
within the network and so this included
proteins like phosphorylated stat 5
which is upstream of cyclin D and bcl-2
or stat 3 which might be part of
immortalizing the cell or f6 which is
part of making protein and as a key
metabolic protein
and so we took this math cytometry panel
and applied it to glioblastoma tumors
and so the general workflow is outlined
here we would enzymatically dissociate
single cells from the tumor Caroline is
going to go through in her slide deck
some of our published work describing
protocols to isolate viable cells from
the tumor so I won't cover that now we
then name the cells from map cytometry
and then in an individual specific way
we would computationally isolate the
cancer cells that go to blastoma cells
from the endothelial and immune cells
within the tumor and so in the lower
left are examples of the number of
cancer cells that we collected that were
good single cell events from each tumor
so the lowest individual had 4860 cells
on the high end we were seeing 300,000
cells or more from the 28 subjects that
are part of the first part of the
analysis I'll show today and since this
work we've actually run many more
samples and it's fairly routine to get
about a hundred thousand to three
hundred thousand selves for me tumor so
the first step of the analysis is an
individual specific tease me to isolate
their cancer cells and so an example of
that is shown on this slide so we have
one tease me map that was tumor specific
and so this was from LC 26 one
individual and the density is shown in
the first upper left and so you can see
that there are very discreet islands on
the t's knee map of phenotypically
similar cells the amount to the right
shows the color for just identifying
what the major islands of cells are so
in red for example are the endothelial
cells we can infer that those are the
endothelial cells by looking at their
marker management modeling label which
is to the right in the red box and so in
a mem label they go from plus ten to
minus ten plus ten means a feature is
highly enriched and fairly specific to
that population of cells minus ten means
that it's specifically lacking from that
population cells relative to
other settles in the analysis so you can
see for example endothelial cells have
CD 31 enriched and lacks EGFR EGFR was a
tumor cell marker and so it's also
lacking from the immune cells that have
cd45 and down in the bottom you can see
the raw data showing the heat of protein
expression on every single on all of the
cells and so you can see cd45 for
example is lighting up the upper-right
island and in the tumor cell island you
can see that there diverse populations
of cells that aberrantly co-expressed
stem cell and differentiated markers for
example sox
2gf AP and cd44 are all Co expressed on
some of those cells and these cells has
distinct sponsor protein signaling
profiles as well as proliferation
profiles
so there are subsets of cells within
each tumor but we want to know which of
these subsets are associated with
differential risk for the individuals in
the study and our prior workflow we
published a modular workflow for data
analysis in 2015 and this workflow is
built off of that one and designed to be
completely automated so to not require
human expertise for the data analysis
and our prior analyses also did not
evaluate outcome and so we wanted
something that could look at continuous
and censored outcomes like overall
survival or progression-free survival
and it would automatically learn the
types of cells that are present in
tissue and so we'll use you mouse or
tease me as dimensionality reduction
tools blow sum is one of our key
clustering tools and markers from
modeling to describe the self and so the
risk assessment population
identification or rapid algorithm is a
machine learning tool or a statistical
learning tool that was designed in an
unsupervised way and a good comparison
point for it is the citric tool which is
another statistical learning tool
published by Rob Bruner in collaboration
with rock tips Ronnie and Gary Nolan in
PNAS and so if we compare these four
sort of features of the algorithm we can
see some of the similarities and
differences between the two tools so for
finding the populations of cells citrus
and rapid or both on supervised
literacies of hierarchical clustering
and part of that means that a cell can
be in more than one cluster within the
hierarchy
whereas for rapid we choose different
tools but we primarily are using low
thumb because it's fast and very
accurate we've also tested K nearest
neighbors and we done slowed some bulk
on the original feature as well as on
the TV axes which you'll see in just a
second all of these are unsupervised
they work really well they're very staff
and T stands let them together provides
kind of the most accurate view of the
cell phenotypes
so the next row is how many cell
clusters to look for and we didn't want
to have to manually stop this and this
is the same in citrus the citrus learns
a appropriate number of clusters and for
citrus each cluster must represent five
percent or more of example and rapid
what we looked for was the fewest
clusters where each marker had low
variation within that cluster and so we
essentially ran the clustering over and
over until we found clusters that were
both stable and fairly uniform or
homogeneous so lastly are some of the
differences between citrus and rabbit so
for modeling the features of the
clusters citrus is supervised and so it
uses the clone cloud come information to
create a model of the key cluster
feature rapid is totally unsupervised
and just uses them to create a simple
statistical description of the clusters
and lastly and this is probably the key
part citrus requires you to assign ahead
of time patience into different groups
and so an expert needs to know a cut
point for survival to group the patients
into good and bad outcome or interest
launders and non-responders and that
needs to happen prior to the beginning
of the algorithm
whereas in rapid the analysis is totally
unsupervised and so it uses statistical
cut points and a human doesn't need to
train it it happens at the end and it
will see that in the next slide okay so
the risk assessment population
identification or rapid algorithm is
outlined on the bottom here so this is
actual data from the patient's where we
pooled an even number of cells from each
of 28 patients and so this was a total
of over 130,000 cells and that's a
common tease me map on the left the
lower left during the density of the
islands and so there are some islands
that are very famous is typically
distinct and then other islands that may
be represented
and phenotypes so in the middle we're an
flow zone on the tease me axes we've
also run it on you map axes and on the
original features but here it's showing
on tease me axes and the rapid algorithm
identified for degree cell cluster as
the optimum number and then in the lower
right we can we ask for each cluster our
patient's higher low for that cluster
and the details of that are in the bio
archives um frequent and then at the
very end we ask is this cluster
associated with differential risk of
death and our first clue that we were on
the right track here is that you can see
that all of the negative outcome
clusters in red are in one part of the
teasing map and all of the four out of
the five good outcome clusters are near
each other in another part of the
teasing about the cells associated with
differential risk were phenotypically
similar and so if we break down what are
the details of these cells or and what
are the details of the clinical outcomes
so the clinical outcomes are shown here
and you can see for example cluster 33
seven patients were high for that
population of glioblastoma cells
and it was associated with very poor
clinical outcomes they can see the
hazard ratios and confidence intervals
here
so we found each of these subsets and
these are they're sort of associated
with differential risk the next slide
shows what is their phenotype so the
negative Prochnow fiction cells are
shown on this slide and one of the key
features of the negative prognostic
cells as modified by the marker modeling
labels
two of the key features were s 100 B and
talked to all four of the negative
prognostic cells were enriched for these
two features they were also negatively
enriched for gfa P at44 and EGFR
regularly and enriched for high basal
signaling especially saw so stat3 in
south coast a5 and saw so at 6 and you
can see that the signaling is what's
distinguishing these clusters from each
other their total protein phenotype
looks fairly similar and if we look at
the raw data we can see for example s
100 be in socks two are co-expressed in
all of these the positive prognostic
cells are essentially the mirror image
of those cells and so they don't express
Docs to wear s 100 B and they do Express
EGFR and they're negatively enriched for
signaling which means that they lacked
faithful signaling in contrast with the
negative prognostic cells and you can
see on the bottom for example EGFR and
344 are two of the key features for
finding these cells
so so this wasn't entirely automated and
unsupervised tool some key questions
from a statistical validation point of
view are are these subset stable across
multiple runs of the analysis are they
independent of known predictors and can
we find them using other tools and I
don't have time to go into all of that
I'll just show the last one and so to
answer the first two questions we run
the analysis over and over it only takes
15 minutes start to finish and positive
and negative prognostic cells with the
same phenotypes are found every time we
run it even when we sample different
cells from the tumors that had hundreds
of thousands or so for the second
question they are independent of all the
known predictors of outcome including
age extent of reception and other
features and that's in the bio a cover
article if you're interested so lastly
we can run the rapid algorithm using
different sort of modules for
dimensionality reduction or clustering
and so we run it with you map instead of
tease me and that's shown on the left
and that also puts patients into groups
of having the negative prognostic cells
with the positive prognostic cells and
you can see in the upper middle we
essentially recover patients in the same
group whether we do the rapid algorithm
with tease me or with you about our
accuracy of finding patients in the same
groups is point eight six which is very
good and in the middle the cells that we
find have the same phenotype whether we
find them looking at clusters on you map
or clusters on teeth knee or on the
original dimensionality so lastly
thinking forward to maybe someday
applying this in the clinic we wanted to
asked as the algorithm work on other
types of clinical research data and can
we find the prognostic cells with other
techniques that might be more clinical
clinically accessible than mass
spectometry like immunohistochemistry
and so the first one is shown here so we
downloaded the data from the
excellent nature Medicine article I been
a good care of Davison Gary Nolan where
they had looked at pre be a well and so
we ran rapid on their data that wasn't
how they had analyzed it they built a
relative risk model that's shown in the
lower left and the three subsets that
were revealed by rapid are highlighted
on this tasting map here and shown in
mem labels on the right and key features
that were found by the authors of the
study in their risk model were also
automatically revealed by the rapid
algorithm so we were really excited
because this showed that the algorithm
works on other data types we can also
find the subsets in simpler ways and so
once we knew the phenotype to go after
we designed by axial gating strategies
to find the subsets if you've seen me
talk before this year we had a seven
marker way of recovering themselves that
gets the cells in the most
phenotypically similar way but the
fewest features we needed define risk
stratifying cells were too and so those
two gates are shown here at ethyl none
would be in EGFR so they're just simple
squared gates on all of the cells and
the patients who are high for these
cells have the differential risks that
are shown in the survival curves on the
right and the phenotypes on the bottom
and essentially we're finding the same
cells with a very simple bag filled
gaming strategy and this is revealing
that there are targetable signaling
events within these cells and that's
something we're really excited about and
the last validation is we designed a
tumor tissue wrecker array with 80 new
sort of additional glioblastoma tissue
samples from 80 different individuals
and measured seven features that were
revealed by the rapid analysis as key
features of these subsets and we were we
built a new model and we were able to
stratify outcome by finding GNP like and
GPP like devils and patients
and so with simple clinically accessible
IHC we can validate the key parts of our
findings as I'll just make one last
point before summarizing so of course
you know that we've measured immune
cells within these and we're very
interested in the micro environment and
questions like contact with the brains
stem cell - the ventricular zone
ventricular zone which our collaborator
the Erie labs has shown is associated
with negative prognostic tumors and so
just a teaser for some of the things
that we'll be talking about in the next
year is shown on this slide so if we
take the patients that whose tumors had
the negative prognostic cells in red or
the positive prognostic cells in blue
and we just ask how many cd45 positive
cells are found within their tumors the
negative prognostic tumors tend to lack
immune infiltrates and the positive
prognostic tumors are very immune rich
and so there's a very different micro
environment with an e2 tumor and so I'll
just conclude by saying that rapid is a
totally automated workflow that's
unsupervised both for finding cell
subsets and for stratifying clinical
outcome it learns the right cell number
the right cluster number and the cut
point are the abundance of the clusters
in the cohort it also describes the
phenotype of the cells automatically
with markers remodeling and it was
designed to work with continuous and
censored variables like overall survival
or progression-free survival and we have
validated it but now with traditional
histology and so the negative prognostic
cells were distinguished by a close
association with an increased risk of
death high basal signaling and an
abnormal neural stem cell identity this
is part of how we know that those cells
are not astrocytes for example we know
that they're cancer cells because they
aberrantly co-expressed many different
markers as well as they're pro
and presently tumors and lastly the
positive prognostic cells were
associated with a decreased risk of
death and especially strongly associated
with a decreased risk of progression
they also have an abnormal neural stem
cell identity and those tumors tended it
can contain a large number of immune
cells and so with that thank you for the
opportunity to present this webinar and
thank you to my outstanding
collaborators and the people that worked
on the study and thank you to our
funding sources which are listed on
bottom and with that I will pass it on
to Caroline who will give the next
section and then I'll come back to
answer questions at the end thank you
thanks Jonathan hi everyone I'm Caroline
roe and I work with Jonathan at
Vanderbilt University managing the mass
spectometry course here and I'll be
talking today about how you can get
started with a possible flow cytometry
at your institution and some things to
look out for when you do
so as Jonathan talked about signaling is
super important and super exciting and
something that's really amazing about
mass spectometry is the ability to
measure 30 or 40 or 50 markers on each
sample gives you an amazing opportunity
to multiplex and this is in true since
the beginning of mass spectometry as you
can see here in this beautiful data set
from john Bendel or jean gondolas in
2011 where they identified 24 cell
subsets in human bone marrow here in the
center in this Spade tree recapitulating
bone marrow development and they were
able to measure using 16 stimulation
conditions 16 different foster protein
readouts on all of these different cell
subsets which creates a really gigantic
heat map of cell subsets versus
stimulation conditions versus readouts
which is really powerful data but can be
overwhelming when you're looking to get
started with fossil as well yourself so
to address that we developed in the lab
a very simplified protocol on using
peripheral blood money to a shell Steven
sees to look at sigmoid so just in brief
we start with viably cryopreserve PBMCs
but you could start with any tissue type
you'd like the immune cells work well
when you're starting out and then we
rest the cells flip them into four
different tubes for four different
conditions of your unstimulated control
and we use il-4 and interferon gamma as
our standard simulation conditions and
then every time we do the experiment
there's one wildcard condition which can
be a different cytokine a drug hydrogen
peroxide anything you're interested and
we stimulate cells for 15 minutes and
then fix to fix that signaling in place
and stain cells with a basic amino
phenotyping panel permeable eyes and
then stain for our five intracellular
fossil markers and we chose the stat and
POC gamma because those work well at our
15-minute time point that we chose for
stimulation and then we collect data on
our Helios mass spectrometer and then
proceed to analysis
and as I mentioned we use peripheral
blood blood but you can really use any
kind of tissue in this protocol so
Long's has been associated into viable
single cells using a protocol developed
in their labs I know in with léa léa
Latium you can start with your
surgically respected patient sample and
we've used everything from fine needle
aspirates to golf ball-sized tumors you
could also use mouse tissue spleen
thymus all work really well and then we
spin it down mince it finely and then
subject it to a one hour in somatic
digestion with collagenous in DNA's and
we use collagenase to filter twice
ACK lice is needed and then viably
cryopreserve
and again this is published and it is a
really straightforward protocol and a
good place to start with any tissue you
might be interested in and we offer it
through our core at Vanderbilt
but anyways once you've collected your
data you'll want to do some manual
cleanup four viable single cells and
here we've dated four cd45 positive
cells because we're using the PBMCs from
that first slide and then we put the
data into our automated data analysis
pipeline in our civil run dimensionality
reduction with you map on all surface
markers except for cd45 because we've
already gated on that and we shows you
map because it really emphasizes the
large differences in the cell
populations which can be useful when you
have so few markers for separating out
your major subsets and then after
dimensionality reduction will run slow
some on the view map axes to get our
cell populations in an unbiased manner
and then we'll characterize those cell
populations either using a marker
expression phosphoprotein expression or
mems marker enrichment modeling to
specifically say what markers are
enriched on the cells compared to the
other cells in the sample
and we found that even with this small
panel its eight marketers um it's quite
sufficient to illustrate all the major
cell populations you would expect and
healthy human blood so you can see here
in the large plot on are you my faxes we
have each population colored by the
flows on cluster that it was assigned to
and then we have density and you can see
as you would expect we have to see three
positive T cell islands one of which is
cd4 positive one of which is cd8
positive and the upper right we have a
CT 19 positive D cell island which is
also hlad our processes as our our CD 14
positive classical monocytes and then
kind of in that lower right we have our
somewhat C 16 positive and K cells and
in addition to these major populations
there are also three smaller populations
that will unfold out um and those would
be our other T cells which are neither
ate nor for positive if we had a PCR
gamma delta in the panel they probably
began with a delta T cells and then we
have our other ap C's which are only HLA
B are positive
there's probably D dendritic cells and
then we have our non classical monocytes
which you can see in the men label on
the bottom are C 16 positive V are
positive and so our data analysis
pipeline not only gives us this plot but
also memo able to reach population which
describe the features I just talked
about in an unbiased manner
and the phenotyping is really
reproducible from replicate to replicate
here we have an experiment where we have
three different trainees rotation
students in the lab put different cryo
vials of the same PBMC from the same
donor through the protocol and you can
see the flows on clustering looks almost
identical from replicates replicate and
the density there's some slight
variation but the islands are
essentially the same and i've quantified
the percent of the sample that each
population made up in the plot on the
right and you can see on the bottom that
the percentages are very consistent and
there's very little deviation one thing
I was noticing this morning looking
through this deck there's a little bit
more variation that you might expect in
your classical monocytes cluster 7 and
that could be because we do the - no
cell sticking to the wall the tube the
myeloid cells tend to be a little
stickier so especially when you're
training people you want to make sure
they're vortexing the tube just to get
those cells off
and in addition to the phenotyping being
very consistent the signalling portion a
stimulation of the protocol is
remarkably consistent and and
importantly reproduces known biology
about the cells so you can see here the
large column blocks are each fossil
readout and then we have each three line
block is a replica with our simulation
conditions across the rows so you can
see as expected interferon gamma goes
step one in that first column and then
we have less signal in this experiment
on Infosys stat3 and stat5 but you can
see a little bit of step process step
three from your il-4 especially in that
middle replica it had a little bit
better signaling and that v we have a
little bit of readout from interfering
gamma but we have really robust off so
step six phosphorylation in all cell
populations in response to aisle 4 which
is useful on one thing to look out for
is if you have a cell population that's
not signaling under any conditions and
you would expect them to you want to
look out for about sample quality as we
say often in the lab Dead Souls don't
signal so it is nice that we see some
signal in all cell subsets on in aisle
four condition and then we have a
phosphorylation of plc gamma and
response to interfere and gamma in our
of our APCs and then in Part B here we
have our wildcard conditions from each
replica the trainee one chose to add
peroxide a classical fossil flow
addition and we got really good a
signaling in our T cells especially and
then Trini to chose of the more
inflammatory il-6
we see nice read out there at Fausto's
step three and then again in our t-cells
il-2 phosphorylating step 5
you
so this protocol is also very easily
modified to any other immune system with
the panel shown earlier and here we have
a case of human console which we like
using in the lab it's a nice model of a
healthy germinal Center lots of these
cells for those who are interested and
we just add cd45 RA and ro to the panel
which when we ran that through our
pipeline it split our cd4 t-cell island
into naive T cells and memory T cells
which was nice to see and add a little
bit more information now you can see as
expected a very large b-cell Island here
and different looking map
but really any cell type is amenable to
this protocol you might want to change
the panel up a little bit if you're
looking at non immune cells as we did in
this experiment we had a very eager
trainee who got a hold of some neural
progenitor cells and developed this
really made a full neural signal panel
and then simulated their neural
progenitor with peroxide and bead EMF
and the GEF didn't quite have the
readout you would expect but we did get
nice signaling in peroxide at her feet
for POC gamma as you can see in the back
field plot in the lower right the cells
responding to peroxide our nest and
positive which is kind of phenotypically
interesting and I was impressed in the
kind of the middle right at our photon
clusters for these this cell type I
really wasn't sure how it would work but
we definitely got some data structure
and it was divided into meaningful
populations for example those nested
positive cells as responding those are
the orange and the dark red population
in the top of that can efficient shape
you
that I'd like to thank Matt Madeline
Hayes our RA who helps all of our IDP
trainees to generate the data in this
presentation and also a dr. Vivian gamma
for giving us the NPCs that you saw on
the last slide and with that all and for
questions
Thank You Jonathan and Caroline for that
informative presentation and we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to answer please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for so let's get started we have quite a
few questions from our audience members
already coming in thank you for your
questions
our first question Jonathan and Caroline
is how much tumour issue is needed and
what type of needle biopsies and
actually this is a three-part question
what what are the type of the needle
biopsies an amount of tissue block these
are great questions and so I think we'll
go particulate so I think Caroline in
her Cora role so we like to have at
least a million viable cells going into
the protocol so whatever amount of
tissue you need to get that um we can
get that from a final aspirating with
them yeah cancer and that's a
conservative estimate for the low end
right and then the another way of
answering it is is always better to have
more yellow hope I want and all the
tissue in all my selves and if you read
the protocols for getting single cell
suspensions out of the tissue talk about
how many millions of cells are usually
released per gram of tissue and it's
tens to hundreds of million a gram
typically and so that can vary widely
like monotype tissues are usually a lot
lower
yeah and so if I needle aspirate for
example of a lymphoma tumor might yield
something like 1 to 5 million sold and
that's the number that you get out of
the cryo vial after thawing and so
that's enough for you know 1 to 5 mass
spectometry samples and those could be
different stimulation conditions or
different panels so there's a long
answer that I think are really important
and with tissue blocks I want to point
out you cannot do the protocol on tissue
that's been frozen so no like cryo
blocks and cannot do it on FFP tissue
you have to have live
shoo
wonderful thank you and our next
question do you have a minimal cell
count for a cluster in order to have
confidence in the statistics yeah so
I'll talk about that a little in the
rapid algorithm it's looking for
clusters that will ratify outcome at the
end of it and so there's not a minimum
number of cells but the cluster won't
stratify outcome if there aren't enough
patients to create a distinct group with
clinical outcome and we are looking for
the smallest number of clusters that are
phenotypically enriched which is to say
they have low variation for each of the
markers and so to get a little bit more
in the weeds when when we're estimating
the right number of clusters we're doing
that in a univariate way we're not
looking at multiple features we're
looking at each feature by itself and
asking whether that feature looks
homogeneous or is you know spread out
and bumpy within the cluster and so
we're looking for fairly large clusters
so lots of cells will tend to be in the
clusters tens of thousands of cells and
but also ideally there will be enough
patients that the patients might be
unusual in their clinical outcomes and
that's the the key is that that
collector won't show up as red or blue
as significant unless there are both a
lot of cells and a lot of patients and
then one other thing we do is we mount
back how many cells came from each
patient and again it's lots of cells
from each patient so it's not like one
patient self dominated the entire
cluster and I forget I don't think we
needed to set a minimum cells number for
the algorithm
because of how it seeks the number of
clusters it tended to give pretty robust
clusters but it's a fantastic question
and anything less than 25 cells per
patient per cluster I'd start to get
pretty skeptical but it's not quite as
high as citrus which has that 5% cut off
I think some of our clusters are 1% or
maybe even less
thank you both for that and again I want
to thank our audience members for these
great questions coming in this next
question from our audience says it's for
both of you and first wants to let you
know that this is a great presentation
and truly is the only question right the
audience member says it is very
difficult to capture the preserve to and
preserve the phospho signal in clinical
samples like the whole blood global
clinical trials during shipping have you
identified any workflows or protocols
that would allow for 24 to 48 hours at
least for signal preservation this is
such an important question
so go ahead Caroline well if you're
looking at basal signaling from tissue
or yeah but um I would suggest honestly
that if your site could process the
tissue or the blood and fix it and then
send it to you and then you could maybe
develop a surface marker panel that was
compatible at those six conditions that
would be your best bet for locking in
your signaling I didn't say that that's
valuable for phenotyping well if you can
fix it in place as close as possible is
it acquiring the together or doing an
experiment with it that's ideal um what
is the name so there's a commercial
products I touch yes I'm kind of it is
several we tested tube yes also the
thing that was developed I was in all in
lab and I'm blanking on the name right
now the Craig double Hani's lab and
others have used that there's a robot
that you can put your tube into and it
does a stimulation and then it fixes the
cells at a certain time and all of that
so
so people have addressed this yeah but I
would say for our studies we have the
way we've addressed it is we do it all
in-house yet the person within a very
short amount of time and all of the
cells that we saw today were viably
cryopreserve
within like a couple hours of coming up
with the bodies so they get
disaggregated and frozen down within
hours but the question is the signalling
changing is if I'm certainly yeah but if
you really even amazed this ship
examples how your phenotyping will
change right cells die off a different
race and that can totally change your
answer so to kind of summarize our
discussion with each other did you
really need to test it and you have it
with things that you know well and so we
when we were testing tubes for fixation
for example we have somebody get the
sample and drive around with it and
after their car for two day and then we
thought what did it look like to
simulate the shipping rush yeah yeah
we've shipped things to ourselves and
yeah or you could change your question
like if you can't preserve signaling at
the site for some reason if they could
send you viola cryopreserved cells that
are high-quality you could do a ex vivo
tree stem in lab and that could give you
more information about the cells
facilities the signal the protocol
variation is the enemy and the shorter
you can make the protocol and the more
you can do immediately after collecting
the matter and really removing the
introduction of variables is key because
the signaling might change it might not
be exactly like in vivo but it still
reflects the type of cell and if you can
do all the collections in a uniform way
that's where we found the best potential
to discover the risk stratifying types
of signals where when we've gone back
and looked in vivo they existed in vivo
as well
we're perfect thank you so much and
Carolina and Jonathan have you tried
doing antibody staining for
transcription factors with the
phosphoprotein stain we always get asked
about it um yeah well I'll save the
stats for example that are in there are
transcription factors um there's some of
the ones that work with us yeah but in
most cases if you have an antibody that
is compatible with these six firm
conditions there's no reason you
couldn't add a transcription factor so
I'm like Fox p3 is very popular but it
requires as gentle term utilizations
that yeah that's not the challenging at
okay talk to the clone we use it also
really finicky if you saw the panel and
the staining steps from my slide the
talks to it the only one done post the
poem and it doesn't work post the
alcohol and there's a fantastic paper
from Peter cryptic back in Gary Nolan's
lab during his PhD where he tests out
different six and perm conditions for
the antibodies and we still return to
that paper and Caroline's protocol for
the rotation students is really a homage
yes
Peter is designed for early courses amid
a little lab and inspired by that and so
a lot of that work was developed during
the fluorescence Otto flow era but it's
still very very relevant for the mess
psychometry antibody validation more and
I said keep in mind yeah and we've even
done like histology conditions and
something so one of the real advantages
of the metal conjugated antibody is is
that they hold up extremely well
compared to some protein fluorochromes
can be killed by fix and current
conditions so you can make the mesh
conditions and do a sequential stain
from the live cell and gentle perm all
the way through harsh alcohol at the end
thank you for that and is there a good
way to normalize the site off data on
different days to minimize batch effect
yeah this is a really hot topic yeah
feels right now there was just a good
tool site of norm we haven't tried out
that came out by Jeff is on goes on and
on seis group who created foot um I've
been hearing good things in the network
about the tool to make that tool work so
it's a computational tool to align
matches across different days you need
the same sample run in each of your
pouches that's a very standard control
for us yeah even if you don't plan on
using the tool have that in there
because it will answer a lot of
questions
yeah so I'm in the best situation should
not have any announcer right whatsoever
and the normalizer software whether you
the nolan lab version of the fluid end
version works pretty well this is baby
normalization you know yeah
normalization of these standards in your
sample works pretty well that you
normalize your signal across phase and
if your instruments well maintained that
will really help you to absolutely I'm
nodding here and I would say compared to
the fluorescence here the batch effects
in mass spectometry are much lower and I
think the bead normalization that's done
standard at the instrument is a really
key nerd of that and it's also just much
more obvious because of that when you do
have batch of fat again and and also
managing the kinds of fashion effect you
have because there's going to be a limit
to how many tubes you can run in the day
but you could maybe stay in more samples
at one time to minimize that pipetting
error in making your antibody master mix
and the study today didn't have bar
coding this bar coding can be another
way to those batches are yeah because
you don't you're not running separate
ood yeah
but I think you know getting the
protocol drilled and doing it with small
numbers of non precious samples
repeatedly until people feel very
comfortable with it is really important
wonderful thank you and again thank you
audience member this next question
starts with what a beautiful talk and
she adds a star for a basic question but
how do you combine SAP as it's happening
and methanol OSA point I would without
in the beginning an opponent and
methanol staining and do you do do you
use them sequentially on the same sample
or you have to choose for your panel
which one you'll use yeah so actually a
lot of the data today has seen the self
esteem votes opponent and methanol all
the brain tumors that panel is designed
to work with those conditions um so
you'll fix yourself first and then
you'll do saponin and that's your gentle
reversible perm and do your sapone and
based any at that time so dr. Irish
mentions box to could also do Triton or
or Triton or any detergent type type
perm you would do at that time and then
wash that out and then you'll put
yourselves do your alcohol perm whether
it's methanol or ethanol and we
typically don't do saponin unless it's
absolutely required for a transcription
factor or something um we look around
for clones that prove that don't ya if
we can keep are you donating to two
steps like in the protocol I should
that's really helpful because you do
lose cells with every staining step so
keep that and it wasn't part of the
questions but there's also a surface
marker staining step usually before all
of that yes it relies stain
preferentially we live things for our
surface markers yeah so the data I
showed with the three-step standing I
think Carolyn to pick up yeah
which is standard
thank you for that this next question is
actually another two-part question and
which kind of abs you used did you use
for the phosphoproteins example P stat1
and generic or site-specific AB for each
phosphoprotein and if there are multiple
crucial fossil sites for one protein are
you going to use different site-specific
abs for that protein okay yeah so it's a
good question so the antibody is when we
say when you see a P - that means the
phospho of the phosphorylated form of
the protein and so those are our
thoughts with specific antibodies and
the second part of it in both total
antibodies and saw so antibodies were
used throughout the study and so the P -
is when it indicates this also and when
it's multiple sites on the same for
example in my PhD thesis if you when I
go back and find it in the archive we do
five different phosphorylation sites on
p53 simultaneously and so it's kind of
amazing that that works but it it does
isn't that far enough apart and so you
can if the antibodies don't sterically
interfere with each other you can get
multiple detection of also protein on
the same target but yeah some antibodies
will block each other and so if you
wanted to do say total protein isazo you
would look for a total protein in a body
that was not blocked by the fossil a
nobody there was maybe in a different
part of the protein
thank you for that and we have time for
a couple of more questions you've got
quite a quite a big fan base here
this next respondent also says great
presentation and her question is about
surface staining post fixation and prior
to man perm did you test any damage to
the epitopes yeah we would definitely
test that during development of a panel
that was designed to use post fix
surface staining Christic knowing traces
yeah yeah we're getting to six just
alright right now yeah so some most of
the episodes will take a very small five
to ten percent sort of hit in the
signal-to-noise that you'll get because
of the fixation it's a one point six
percent for both hide for and yeah and
then there are some episode that will be
totally destroyed by the fixation and so
to the ones that come to mind are at
8016 clone we use in an igt clone that
we have is will be killed by six and so
then you have to look around for
different clones cd19 and see a twenty
are also very sensitive to fix and so
proceed twenty on B cells and activated
T cells we as the act an intercellular
clone so it's a h1 is the name of the
clone against intracellular portion of
it 80/20 and so all of these are like
key antibody questions that aren't
necessarily enough cytometry specific
but if you're trying to get forty four
and if I can gather in a family
companies yeah regularly are going to
come up we also have other panels that
we've designed to be against CD markers
but work after fix and methanol purnam
and so we have a list of antibodies that
work well in that condition and that's
really helpful if you want to do one
staining condition minimize the number
of washes you're doing and kind of get
all done at once but you know the
epitope could work differently when
you're standing intracellular than with
so keep that in mind thank you for that
we have time for one more question and
this one's for you Jonathan how do you
imagine these results being used to
design new clinical studies could the
signalling or immune signatures you saw
be used to guide trial designs this
great question this is something that
we're actively thinking about right now
and so I think I'm hopeful that both of
those could be used to design new
studies and we're actively looking
around right now for partners who are
interested in doing that I think that
this is going to be done in a
multicenter way but for example we saw
that the negative and prognostic self
had different signaling and different
immune infiltrates and we're looking
right now to see whether their MRI
imaging features or sort of non-invasive
features that we could use that
correlate with signaling and immune
infiltrate and we're starting to find
some of those so one that I'll mention
is our collaborator to Erie lab is
really interested in contact with the
ventricular stem cell niche that the SCC
is called and that's a negative outcome
feature and our post October Kupiec is
founded that's connected to immune cell
infiltrate and to signaling so all of
the different features that we measure
on mass spectometry seem to be connected
to things that we can also see on MRI
imaging that would be really exciting I
think to design a study where we could
be could we track patients on two
different immunotherapy arms checkpoint
inhibitors or something to go without
but I think we're really going to need
to use this biology to match new
inhibitors to the signaling that we saw
in the selves and to pair combinations
of signaling inhibitors and
immunotherapies and do that in a way
where the signaling inhibitors don't
blunt or destroy the beneficial immune
response that we're hoping to get so
a complicated question and we'd love to
work on it with other people out there
if they're interested thank you Jonathan
Caroline thank you so much for your
presentation today and for clearly
important research do you have any final
comments for our audience members before
we go today
plan ahead yeah yeah keep humans in mind
wind design yeah protocol so keep it
simple and yeah as many sets of yawns
yes that's great and thank you again for
this great presentation I'd also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor fluid
I'm for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go I want to thank our
audience for joining us today and
further interesting questions questions
we didn't have time to answer today and
those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via their contact information provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand and lab routes
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share this email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time bye bye